what do you make of this five six three
three what do you think comes next
I'm gonna go seven seven
no actually it's another three now you
have a guess what's coming next three
good yes as a matter of fact that
continues to be three three three
and you wonder this is really a strange
sequence you know what we're gonna do
with this well this is the number of
regular polytopes that exist in three
four five six seven eight nine and all
higher dimensions and that's what we're
going to talk about today regular
polytopes in then dimensions a polytope
is just a more general term that
generalizes two-dimensional polygons
3-dimensional polyhedra and everything
higher we call a regular polytope that
sounds a little scary so let's start
with something much simpler than
platonic solid so here is a tetrahedron
that's the first atomic solid next we
have simple cube third one octahedron
made from eight equilateral triangles
number four well faces dodecahedron this
one has 12 Pentagon's and finally the
real jewel the akiza he drew on made out
of NT equilateral triangles and this is
probably a Swiss crystal and here is
another view of an icosahedron they said
half on the MC escher
could you show to a non mathematician in
an intuitive way why there are exactly
five photonic solids not more and not
less well one way to do it is to look at
the surface of these objects so
historically done for instance is made
out of regular Pentagon's and so all of
these latronnik solids are made out of
regular polygons so probably we should
step down a dimension and look at what
regular polygons are possible simplest
one would be a regular equilateral
triangle then we can do a square then we
can do a Pentagon then we can do an
hexagon and so on and if you go all the
way to infinity we end up with something
that looks like a circle so they're
infinitely many of these regular
polygons into them
so really the sequence up here it has
another character before the five if we
go to two dimensions and what's that
it's not eight its infinity and if you
really want to go to the extreme what
about one dimension well it's just a
line segment nothing else what about
zero dimension well it's just a point
nothing else but now 1 1 infinity 5 6 3
3 3 3 3 3 that's a really weird sequence
you know and I guess I would really
confuse people
ok all the platonic solids are made from
one of these regular polygons and so how
many different ways can we use these
regular polygons to make one of these
solids start with the hecka lateral
triangle and ask how can we make a tonic
solid out of that one well we need a
minimum of three of those to be put
around the corner in order to make a
valid corner in three dimensions and if
we put three of these triangles around a
shared vertex then the bottom is also an
equilateral triangle that would give us
a tetrahedron okay so next we can try to
put four equilateral triangles around
the shared vertex and we can bring them
together and make a four-sided pyramid
and remember to make it regular all of
the dihedral angles here have to be
exactly the same so that means that the
bottom now is a perfect square we can
take this square pyramid and match it
with an identical square pyramid so that
makes the second platonic solid the
octahedron now we can try to take live
of those and put them around a vertex
and this makes this five sided pyramid
so it's completely symmetrical if we
continue forming these kind of corners
and try to solve wrap it around will
this actually get the closed surface
will this actually end up in something
something useful well we know we have
this equals ahead on okay but if you
have to really figure out whether it
works it takes a little thinking you can
see on top here meaning half this five
sided pyramid that we can take one of
these five sided pyramids we cannot put
this one just up on the mirror you can
take another one but the two have to be
rotated against one another by 36
degrees and if you do that then in
between you can see there's a triangle
strips triangles going up down up down
up down essentially forming a five sided
anti prism adding ten more triangles
it's kind of beautiful that indeed this
surface does close and result in number
three but
solid what about six triangles oh good
question glad you asked that so let's
try to take six triangles and put them
together and we get a wonderful nice
hexagon here so unfortunately it's
totally flat and so this doesn't really
curve and it doesn't help you to make
some kind of closed object you can make
a kitchen floor is that one now we go to
seven triangles they don't even fit into
the plane it's kind of get that warped
shape that is no good so they're done
with triangles so now we have to go to
squares fold them up so basically three
squares around the share of the vertex
Leafs of an opening of ninety degrees
and we forcefully try to close this
opening and now we have a valid 3d
corner if you take a contraption like
that and match it on the backside was
exactly the same contraption then you
get a cube made out of six squares I
know what you're going to ask next what
about four squares well glad you asked
same problem here so we can put four
squares together and they make either a
complete flat or if you were to somehow
bend it in in in weird ways then not all
the dihedral angles that all the edges
would be the same and so it not would be
a regular corner that's unuseful so
we're done with squares we can put three
handguns together and form a nice 3d
corner and again the question arises
does that really close if we continue
the process and the easiest way to see
it is it takes of one Pentagon and put
five Pentagon's around it completing
five of these corners and this makes
this nice kind of salad bowl and now if
we put another salad bowl like that on
top of it again rotate by 36 degrees so
it fits nicely together then indeed we
can convince ourselves very quickly that
this leads to yet another regular
platonic solid trying to put four of
these Pentagon's around the corner
exceeds a total of 360 degrees so you
already get something that's warped like
a potato chip and it's no good the
boundaries Pentagon's hexagons you know
what happens with sley hexagons of
course very flat tiling
that's no good what about hexagons well
they don't even visually fit into a
plane right so it's too much so from
there on up they're sort of done nothing
new can happen and now you know exactly
why there are five platonic solids and
exactly five platonic solids professor
is a sphere of platonic solid no it
isn't because even if you think about a
very fine tessellation you could not
find a tessellation on the sphere where
all the faces would be exactly the same
and all the edges are all the same and
all the vertices are the same so we're
basically done with three dimensions and
so I must admit that for many of us is
indeed a sixth platonic solid and it is
the Utah teapot for the people in the
computer graphics community this is such
a famous object which has been used
again and again to test out rendering
software and solid modeling software and
it just shows up in just about every
sick rap a per in some form an hour so
we like to think of it as the sixth
platonic solid now these regular
polytopes are made out of regular
polytopes one dimension lower in the
same way that we made atomic solids out
of 2d regular polygons we can now try to
make four-dimensional regular polytopes
out of three-dimensional platonic solids
each one of these four dimensional
regular polytopes is of an object that
has as a surface a thick crust of
three-dimensional platonic solids and
just like we made a cube out of squares
they're now trying to make a hypercube
out of cubes in its surface we used to
take three squares and then forcefully
try to close this gap of 90 degrees and
by closing it we force this corner to
pop out of two dimension become a three
dimensional valid polyhedral corner and
that's the corner of a cube now they're
doing exactly the same thing except
think that behind each one of these
squares there is a complete cube and
these three cubes now are sharing a
joint edge perpendicular to this plane
in in that particular corner so there's
a 90 degree wedge of open space and
they're trying to forcefully close that
and we cannot close that in three
dimensions if they're cubes behind each
one of these for visible squares but
trust me if we really do that and we can
pop out in the fourth dimension we can
close up you know these cubes and we get
a hypercube those cubes behind things
that are
being asked to imagine they've kind of
overlapped with each other now
no because they pop out into
four-dimensional space in the same way
that when we took these two-dimensional
squares and we force them to close
they didn't overlap they just popped out
of two dimensions into three dimensions
and four dimensional space is really
much bigger than three dimensional space
so is ample room for these cubes to
simply pop out and form a true
four-dimensional corner but to my
three-dimensional eyes
he is sitting in 3d space I'm like how
did that happen but if I had
four-dimensional eyes I'd be thinking oh
that's correct and now you're hitting on
the real problem so we can figure out
that this must be possible but then can
we visualize that I mean how did you
know what what this thing looks like
well for that we have to use some kind
of a shadow or a projection of a four
dimensional object down into three
dimensional space and I'm sort of torn
between you know should we use a shadow
or should we use what I would call a
wireframe and you see the trade-off
between those two options just like if I
show you the wireframe of the
dodecahedron you can really see through
it and it tells you much more than if
you just had a faceless shadow of this
object you can eventually start to get a
feeling by looking at three dimensional
wireframes or projection of such fire
frames what the four dimensional object
might indeed look like in doing this
projection we still have an option we
can project in various different ways
we're going from a two dimensional
Square to a three dimensional object and
in an oblique projection I start with
the Red Square in front and then the
Blue Square is the one sub in the back
and the green lines essentially show me
the depths we can do the same thing by
starting with a complete cube the red
cube is in front Liu cube is in the back
and then the green lines show
essentially extrusion of this Q in this
oblique direction alternatively we can
use a perspective projection everything
in the back would appear smaller and we
can look straight at the face and by
doing that you know the back face will
be a smaller squares of really behind a
red square and the green lines show kind
of the depths they're going from the
front to the back and the same we can do
is the complete cube and we get you know
in the back
all the cubes shown in blue and then the
edges that go from the front to the back
are shown in green so here is the
oblique projection you can see the fat
for cube beings of the one in front and
then the thinner cube in the back and
then the slightly conical edge is
leading from the front to the back so
that's a valid depiction of a wireframe
of a hypercube and here is the
alternative model a perspective
projection so the blueish cube is the
front cube and the yellow cube is the
one in the back which is here much
smaller the red edges that go from the
front to the back and this hypercube has
a total of eight cubes the front cube in
blue the back cube in yellow and then
some squashed cubes here showing one on
each of six faces so there's a total of
eight cubes making the surface or the
thick crust of the hypercube say that
yellow cube isn't inside the blue you
know in four dimensions it would piece
of up in the fourth dimension a certain
distance because of perspective
projection what's further up there you
know it gets projected into the back and
appears smaller in this projection now
we're gonna systematically look at all
the Platonic solids see how many we can
group around the shared edge how much
empty space there is and then we push
that one out and push that into a valid
for the corner the Simplot object to
start with is the tetrahedron the
tetrahedron has a dihedral angle of 70
and a half degrees we need at least
three of these tetrahedral around the
edge to make a valid corner three of
course fits very easily for fits even
five fits but just barely we just have a
few degrees left and so when we try to
fit five tetrahedron around this we just
get a little bit bending in four
dimensional space and we will need as we
will see a whole lot of these tetrahedra
make it actually work out so we can
start out with three tetrahedra and ask
what happens if we forcefully you know
paint that into a corner can be repeated
and the answer is we will get the
simplex or of the five cell so because
of the projection you know it becomes
just a three dimensional object and it
loses some of its symmetry so we have
five vertices but the fifth one to me
make it as symmetrical as possible I put
here right in the middle so we get the
outer tetrahedron
and then we get the dimples here on each
side they all represent additional four
tetrahedra and they don't look very
regular and that's because of the
projection but in four dimensional space
all five of these tetrahedra are
completely irregular and so that's the
five cell or the simplex that's what
happens when you take three tetrahedra
around the shade of H and essentially
force out the empty space and bend them
into a true four dimensional corner four
tetrahedra around the corner yeah we get
this object here okay it's called the
cross polytope and it's actually the
dual of the hypercube that we've seen
before
okay so that's the cross pollito the
second regular polytope in four
dimensions 5 tetrahedra put it around
the sheer edge you get something that
has a lot of tetrahedra as a matter of
fact this thing has 600 tetrahedra most
of them are so crunched up in the middle
here because of the projection and you
just see one giant tetrahedra on the
outside and then adjacent to each faces
you see smaller fairly much flattened
out tetrahedra and you have to just
believe me that in there they're
essentially in addition to this one out
here another 599 ATRA Hedra this is
called the 600-cell six tetrahedra would
exceed the dihedral angle of 360 degrees
and that's like you know something
warped that is not regular so that's of
no use we have seen cubes they have phi0
angles of 90 degrees three of them move
it around an axis still leave an open
gap and then we fold this one up we've
seen we get the hypercube if you try to
put four cubes around the joint axis you
can readily visualize that would readily
fill the space without any bending and
so he can tile all of 3-dimensional
space with that but it will never Bend
and make a regular polytopes in the
higher dimension so we were done with
the cubes the next platonic solids we
may want to try is the octahedron it
hasn't I he'd roll angle of 109 and 1/2
degrees so that's less than 120 degrees
here and that means we can indeed fit
three around a joint edge and still
leave a little bit open space which we
can squeeze
and make this then pop into the fourth
dimension and the result is what I
believe to be the most beautiful four
dimensional regular polytope the 24 cell
made up of 24 octahedra you can see the
outermost octahedron because I chose
that to be you know preserved in the
projection but then you see these rather
flattened octahedron this one triangle
here another triangle the small one here
and survey and distorted anti prism in
between and then they're more on the
inside I really like this particular
object the most because it's not too
complex you can still see what's going
on you can still look on the inside and
see the innermost very tiny little
octahedron at the center now it turns
out this object has 1152 symmetries in
four dimensional space and then you
simply get that by multiplying the
symmetries of an octahedron which are 48
missed a number of octahedra 24 you
multiply this out you get the eleven
hundred and fifty-two because you can
take in four-dimensional space any one
of the octahedron and put in place by
suitable rotation of any one of the
other 24 octahedra in any one of the 48
possible positions I live at the street
address 1152 and then I found out that
this object has 1152 symmetries I
thought that somehow fate really meant
me to be you know into geometry the next
one on the list is the dodecahedron is
116 and half degrees of a dihedral angle
that is still less than 120 degrees so
we can still force three of them around
an edge and then join them into a valid
four-dimensional corner it's not bending
all that much and so we will need a
hundred and twenty of those objects in
the crust to form a valid
four-dimensional regular polytope so
this is a model of the hundred 20 cell
course you can see the outermost otk
Hedren you can also see kind of this
flattened pancake like you know Datuk
hater on top here and each one of the
faces has one of those and then stacked
on the inside there
you more adding up to a total of a
hundred and twenty of those we still
have the Eco so Iran unfortunately it
has a very shallow tehy tall angle it is
more than 120 degree it is actually a
hundred thirty-eight degrees roughly and
so even three of them would not fit
around this edge without overlapping and
so we cannot form a valid corner and
unfortunately this is useless as far as
making a four dimensional regular
polytope you basically can figure it out
yourself right you know how to make five
dimensional regular polytopes you look
at the or dimensional regular polytopes
look at their dihedral angles and figure
out you know can I fit at least three of
them around an edge so I can make a
valid corner most of these regular
polytopes the four dimensions are very
round and they're not very useful
they're really only two of them that
actually have some hope of generating a
new regular polytopes entire dimension
one of them is the simplex or the five
cell and the other one is the hypercube
yeah the other one have two shallows of
dihedral angles and they just don't make
valid chorim's in the next higher
dimension and so from five dimensions
onwards
they're really only just three regular
polytopes in each one of these
dimensions one is the simplex series you
can always make a simplex by taking a
simplex in a particular dimension I'm
starting mr. tetrahedron and then I put
another vertex at the center of gravity
and now I used the fourth dimension and
essentially raised this vertex up in the
fourth dimension until it has exactly
the same distance from all the other
four vertices that makes a new simplex
and then I can take that particular
simplex put the new vertex at its center
raise it up at the next higher dimension
until it is exactly the same distance
from all the previously existing
vertices and make the next simplex that
always works so I can work my way up to
infinity by always making an additional
simplex in exactly that manner the
problem now is how do we depict those
things because clearly projecting it
down it could do anything so it's better
to figure out how do we make a model
that has the right connectivity even
though the geometry really sort of bogus
at
this point because it's so much
distorted from what we originally have
and I have made a few more simply
seasoned higher dimensions you just need
to always add one more vertex and then
figure out how to make a nice little
graph that will get the right
connectivity so this one has six
vertices I claim this is a projection of
the 5 D simplex because the simplex also
is the complete graph every vertex is
connected directly to every other vertex
you can see in this case you start at
any one vertex there 5 H is going off
one to each of the other vertices so we
want to make a 3d model that has six
corners is reasonably symmetric but not
too symmetric so we could start with an
octahedron but in the octahedron then
when you connect opposite vertices those
three edges will all intersect in the
middle that would be so nice you
wouldn't see what's going on so you have
to deliberately distort this octahedron
warp it a little bit so that those three
spaced diagonals that go through the
middle of the regular octahedron they
have separated out and now they do not
intersect with each other anymore so the
trick was really just finding six
vertices in a relatively symmetrical
arrangement so we can connect every one
with every other one without any
intersections and that's the game that
we have to play for everyone after the
dimensions that we want to build a
simplex model we already have this
object that had six vertices completely
connected the borp octahedron and that
actually has a extra free space in the
center and it's so easy therefore to put
a seventh vertex right here in the
center this one can again be connected
to all the other vertices and so now we
have a complete graph of seven vertices
and that would be a nice model of a six
dimensional simplex there is a second
sequence that works for all dimensions
and it's called the measure poly tope or
hypercube sequence the cube is the
object with which we measure the volume
of three-dimensional space just like the
square is the geometric elements that we
use to measure two-dimensional space
similarly the hypercube would measure
four dimensional space so the measure
polytopes are always the equivalent of a
cube in the higher dimensions and the
best way of visualizing what's going on
is essentially going in stepwise in x3
so we start with a line and then we take
this line and extrude it basically into
a square and then we sort of take that
square and extrude it perpendicular to
itself into a cube and then we're doing
one more extrusion of that cube into a
hypercube do an extrusion of the
hypercube into the 5t measure Polito and
you could continue that way or you can
change the scale so what I prefer maybe
in six dimensions would be to take a
regular cube and essentially sweep it in
three different dimensions to makes of a
thickened cube frames which is showing
every edge as the sweep path of one of
those cubes so this particular diagram
would be a depiction of a 6 dimensional
hypercube which you get by extrusion
another projection of this extra mental
hypercube results in this rhombic try a
counter hydron which has 30 rhombic
faces on the outside but on the inside
there's a whole lot of intersecting
edges going on and you may not like that
though it all depends on what you really
want to get out of your model in some
sense this makes a very nice of climbing
structure for children yeah for some
angles if you look at here it looks like
an oblique kind of squash to cube it
starts as one of the cube face or a very
flattened cube you know you have just
like three faces here and then on the
inside there will be another three flat
faces but they of course already
intersect with edges from some of the
other cubes that is correct so you know
we started out with the five platonic
solids we went to the six regular
polytopes in four dimensions and after
that I said three three three three
three I have shown you two of those
three series the simplex series and then
the measure polytope series so there
must be another one we've seen that we
can make a series of measure polytopes
through all the dimensions in each one
of these dimensions we can also form the
dual just like in three dimensions we
have the cube and then we have its dual
which is the octahedron and then hold it
that way you can see the top and bottom
vertex in my right hand correspond to
the top and bottom face in this
particular queue or each of the six
faces in the cube I now have a vertex
and for each of the vertices in the cube
I now have a face
twin yep nice twins actually so they're
they're duals of one another we also
have the models that show the same
relationship now quite as obvious in
four dimensions so here we have the
measure poly tope the hypercube and if
we take the eight cubes in the crust of
the hypercube and replace them by eight
vertices we get the corresponding
measure poly tope which is the dual to
this hypercube and the same principle
goes on it to get self near-impossible
to kind of visualize in higher
dimensions but again either every
measure polytope in D dimension is made
out of measure polytopes of D minus one
dimension you replace each one of those
cells is a vertex at its center and
connect them properly and you get the
cross polytope which is the dual to the
measure polytopes in in any one of these
dimensions and that's the third series
that we can form here is again our
sequence you know we have infinitely
many polygons in two dimension we have
five platonic solids in three dimensions
six wholly topes in four dimensions and
from there on it's just always only
three regular polytopes so in
conclusions I think I can say we're self
lucky that we live in one of the two
dimensions where it's really interesting
and we have a variety of different
regular polytopes we don't live in the
most interesting dimension though we
live in a second most interesting well
if you think that we live in space-time
continuum which is four-dimensional so
we live in that one too so I'm inside a
four dimensional politic right now yes
you're inside the 120 cell space is
entirely filled with dodecahedron
because in this spherical space though
to keep your tile space it's it's non
Euclidean